auch in dieser nacht erneut heftige
angriffe durch russisches militär in der
ukraine
dabei wurde das krankenhaus von sturm
ihr westlich von kiew laut
stadtverwaltung zerstört zwei menschen
wurden getötet zehn verletzt
videomaterial das bisher noch nicht
verifiziert werden konnte der 60
kilometer lange russische militär konvoi
der sich auf die hauptstadt zu bewegt
kommt laut vitali klitschko immer näher
gustav einzieht seine truppen näher an
die hauptstadt heran die stadt biel
azerca wurde gestern nach beschossen
kämpfe gibt es auch in butter und
rostock wir machen uns bereit und wir
werden unsere stadt verteidigen vor den
vereinten nationen in new york
verurteilt die deutsche außenministerin
das vorgehen der russischen truppen
stark
sie sagen russland schickt
friedenstruppen aber ihre panzer
transportieren kein wasser keine
babynahrung sie transportieren auch
keinen frieden
ihre panzer transportieren tod und
zerstörung
bombardierungen insbesondere auch im
süden und osten der ukraine in der
hafenstadt mario pohl am asowschen meer
sind zivile einrichtungen wohnblocks und
behelfsmäßige unterkünfte unter beschuss
laut stadtverwaltung ist mario pohl
unter russischer kontrolle schwere
zerstörung auch nach den angriffen auf
die stadtrat tief im osten des landes
dabei wurde das verwaltungsgebäude
getroffen und schwer verletzte geborgen
laut behörden kamen seit gestern
mindestens 21 menschen durch
bombardements ums leben mehr als 112
wurden verletzt
auch person im süden des landes ist laut
lokalen behörden von russischen truppen
umzingelt man geht davon aus dass
russland sich den zugang zur krim
sichern will
mit den angriffen auf den fernsehturm
gestern in kiew wurde auch die
holocaust-gedenkstätte barbie nja
getroffen sie liegt in unmittelbarer
nähe der
ukrainische präsident der lenski erfährt
vom beschuss während eines interviews
sie beschießen jetzt bin ja
die gedenkstätte und die sich vor 80
jahren gebaut haben
[Musik]
das ist russland sagt zielinski und
herzlichen glückwunsch
gespenstische ruhe und immer wieder
bomben alarm nicht nur in der hauptstadt
kiew viele sind geflohen andere
verstecken sich auch heute am siebten
tag des russischen einmarsches in die
ukraine
zur einordnung der militärischen lage
haben wir unsere heute unterstützung
geholt und zugeschaltet nun oberst ag
wolfgang richter 1 leiten der
militärberater der deutschen osze
vertretung nun bei der stiftung
wissenschaft und politik
forschungsbereiche unter anderem militär
strategische fragestellung und das nato
russland verhältnisses günter richter
guten tag herr pontzen errichtet wie
bewerten sie die jüngsten militärischen
entwicklungen und welchen weiteren
verlauf erwarten sie jetzt
hier sehen vier strategische kräfte
gruppierungen die eine von norden her
kommend wird versuchen die hauptstadt
zunächst einmal zu umzingeln vielleicht
werden einzelne kräfte auch in die
hauptstadt eindringen das strategische
ziel ist klar es geht um den regierungen
sturz in der hoffnung dass dann
vielleicht eine pro russische regierung
den befehl an die ruß an die
ukrainischen streitkräfte gibt den kampf
aufzugeben wir sehen aber auch von süden
her von der krim kommen zwei richtungen
einmal nach osten der landkorridor bis
zum
donnerstag schon hergestellt es gibt
noch ein streifen zwischen bert jansch
und mario pohl der noch aussteht da
erwarte ich kämpfe nach westen hin geht
es jetzt darum über kasan in richtung
odessa vorzustoßen dann wäre auch diese
küstenlinie völlig abgeriegelt auch
gegenüber
hilfslieferungen und die weitere kräfte
kopp gruppierung neben dem don bass
kommt von nordwesten her in richtung
charkiw und hier wird es darauf ankommen
nicht nur die stadt zu nehmen sondern
weiter vorzustoßen bis zum japan wir
sehen auch vorstöße von süden über sapa
roche herkommen wenn das gelingt da
hätten die russischen streitkräfte etwa
bei nico die ukrainischen streitkräfte
im donbass abgeriegelt dann müssten sie
entweder sich dort vorher zurückziehen
oder aufgeben und dann wird der kampf
allerdings weitergehen weil der
widerstand wieder schon geschildert
worden war der ukraine ist
bewunderungswürdig und es wird natürlich
deutlich dass der preußische vormarsch
erheblich an fahrt abgenommen hat dass
das nicht so schnell gegeben wie man
erwartet hatte und wer das zur
straßenkämpfen käme innerhalb einer
stadt oder gar zu luftangriffen
dann würde das eine ziemlich schmutzige
angelegenheit werden und ich frage mich
was passiert eigentlich in moskau wenn
so viele hunderte oder tausende von
russischen soldaten in särgen
zurückkommen und man dann die frage
gestellt wer ist eigentlich
verantwortlich für einen krieg zwischen
brüdern welche hoffnungen daran
anknüpfen welche hoffnungen sehen sie
auch angesichts der russischen
forderungen die ja genannt wurden
entmilitarisierung der ukraine zum
beispiel und mindestens ja der anspruch
auf einzelne gebiete sehen sie da
überhaupt möglichkeiten für eine
verhandlungslösung
solange russland an diesen forderungen
festhält die er für die ukraine
unannehmbar sind sehe ich im moment
keine verhandlungslösung gefällt es
überhaupt schwer jetzt wege zu sehen aus
über die putin gesichtswahrend
herauskommen kann aus diesen krieg denn
er hat ja das ziel gesetzt die russe die
ukrainische regierung die als
faschistisch bezeichnet abzusetzen und
durch eine durch ein anderes regime zu
ersetzen
das ist ein narrativ wenn das nicht
gelingt hätte eine schwere niederlage
hinzunehmen und wenn dann der
militärische vormarsch auch noch stockt
dann ist der reputationsverlust
natürlich deutlich nun sind ja bereits
viele starken nato staaten in den
konflikt hineingezogen indirekt mit
waffenlieferungen der französische
wirtschaftsminister sprach nun zudem von
einem zitat totalen finanz und
wirtschaftskrise den mann russland und
liefere wie groß ist da aus ihrer sicht
die gefahr dass es tatsächlich auch zu
einem direkten krieg zwischen russland
nato
man sollte die eskalation risiken nicht
unterschätzen aber nicht in reaktion auf
sanktionen auf die sich putin vielleicht
eingestellt hat sondern vor allen dingen
dadurch dass wir natürlich sehr viele
truppenbewegungen haben nicht nur an den
landgrenzen sondern auch auf der sie
über der hohen see
mit schiffen und flugzeugen die sich
sehr nah gekommen da kann natürlich
immer ein zwischenfall passieren und wir
müssen sehr aufpassen dass ein solcher
zwischenfall nicht eskaliert und
deswegen wird man auch im krieg noch
gewisse
kommunikationskanäle offen halten müssen
vor allen dingen zwischen militärischen
hauptquartiere um zwischenfälle
einerseits zu verhindern oder wenn sie
passieren zu deeskalieren inwieweit das
möglicherweise auch mit washington
möglich ist darauf kommen wir später in
der sendung noch zu sprechen oberster de
wolfgang richter vielen dank für die
einordnung vielen dank für das gespräch
danke herr ja und wir schauen nun in die
ukraine zu meiner kollegin katrin
eigendorf die aus dem kriegsgebiet für
uns berichtet aktuell ist kathrin für
uns in schnell mit ski im westen der
ukraine
katrin wie stellt sich die lage dort
aktuell da
ja der krieg wird hier auch immer
präsenter wir hatten gestern abend
innerhalb einer halben stunde fünf mal
alarm mussten hier in den schutz keller
unseres hotels gehen wir haben heute
morgen hier im zentrum in unsere
frühsendung geschaltet direkt nach der
schalter hat es auch wieder alarm
gegeben und als wir uns dann auf den
rückweg gemacht haben haben wir uns nun
über uns auch einen kampfjet fliegen
hören 120 kilometer entfernt von hier
hat es auch einen angriff der russen auf
eine munitionsfabrik gegeben es ist wohl
so dass die russen zwar ihre kräfte im
moment darauf konzentrieren kiew
einzunehmen und auch im osten der
ukraine
immer weiter vorstoßen aber sie werden
ihre angriffe auch im zentrum des landes
hier verstärken und das macht den
menschen natürlich große angst also man
muss auch hier damit rechnen dass es
jederzeit zu einem luftangriff kommen
können und darauf bereiten die leute
sich vor trotz dieser angst der menschen
von der sie gar sprechen hören wir
sich in der ukraine immer mehr menschen
freiwillig melden um gegen die
russischen truppen zu kämpfen auch
frauen was bekommen sie davon mit
ja das erleben wir hier auch im zentrum
der stadt gibt es eine büro- und sie
sehen das ja hinter mir es ist hier
nicht warm sondern wirklich kalt dort
stehen männer stundenlang in der
schlange
seit mehreren tagen schon um sich
anzumelden zu den waffen entweder zur
armee oder zu den volks verteidigungs
gruppen jeder wird der einzelne
abgefragt was kann er was für waffen hat
er alle männer die wir sehen die in der
schlange stehen sind bereit für irland
in den kampf zu ziehen und entschlossen
auch wenn es keine professionellen
militärs sind also die widerstands-
bereitschaft der ukraine ist ungebrochen
aber natürlich wächst die angst mit den
bildern die wir auch zu sehen bekommen
mit der brutalität mit der russland hier
vorgeht auch gegen zivilisten
was wir allerdings auch hören ich kann
es hier nicht überprüfen ist dass die
moral der russischen bodentruppen doch
immer weiter zu sinken scheint je mehr
sie mit der ukrainischen bevölkerung
auch zusammentreffen wir haben gehört
dass zum beispiel es russische soldaten
gegeben hat die die tanks ihrer panzer
kaputt gemacht haben damit sie nicht
weiter vorstoßen können wir können das
von hier nicht überprüfen es gibt
einfach so viele informationen die hier
jeden tag
ja im prinzip veröffentlicht werden das
immer nur versuchen müssen uns ein bild
in der gesamtlage zu machen aber es
scheint wirklich durch verschiedene
quellen auch belegt dass die russen mit
ihren bodentruppen hier nicht so
schnelle erfolge erzielen werden und das
möglicherweise ja wie gesagt die moral
nicht die beste ist also eigentlich
vielen dank für die schilderung vielen
dank dass sie zu diesem informationsbild
ganz erheblich beitragen aus der grüne